доки Патріарх Кирило не засудить війну
для мене абсолютно природно вважати що
його слід включити до санкційного списку
а потім ми скаржимося що ці санкції не
принесли очікуваного результату але це
тому що ці санкції ймовірно були занадто
слабкими
Наразі я не бачу жодних ознак вдома
особливо в моїй країні тому що я бачу як
практично 99% людей від щирого серця
підтримують Україну
є членом ЄС та НАТО а також потужною
прихильницею України
лідер Китаю всі дінь-пін розмовляв з
президентом України Володимиром
Зеленським вперше після повномасштабного
вторгнення Росії що почалося торік ви
теж з ним говорили Яка ваша думка чи
може Китай стати мирним посередником
На мою думку Китай має шанси стати
важливим гравцем на міжнародній арені і
звичайно Він міг би також стати
посередником у війні Росії проти України
але за однієї умови поки що ми не бачили
і не чули нічого про засудження цієї
війни з боку Китаю і це дуже важливо
розуміти Китай на боці Росії чи на боці
міжнародного порядку заснованого на
правилах І доки Китай вагається щоб
зайняти чітку позицію щодо цього дуже
важко повірити що він може бути надійним
посередником у цьому конфлікті звісно
також ширяться чутки про підтримку
Китаєм Росії з метою обійти санкції що
були запровадження ЄС та іншими країнами
однодумцями і це теж не дуже добре
ознака і Звичайно це не додає
упевненості аби довіряти Китаю
Чи міг би візит лідера КНР сізінпіна до
Києва посилити цю впевненість це можна
назвати такою умовою
що це був би дуже важливий візит Але
знову ж таки якщо ми говоримо про мирні
переговори дуже важливо усвідомлювати що
визначальним тут є голос українців і
україна має сама вирішити на які умови
вона готова піти на мою думку однією з
найважливіших складових цих мирних
переговорів Є повага до територіальної
цілісності України ідеться про країну
частина території якої окупована 20%
території України окуповані Росією це те
що стосується території а щодо передумов
мирних переговорів дуже важливо уникнути
торгів від імені України а також не йти
на жодні територіальні поступки за
рахунок України Я вважаю що це
несправедливий шлях мирних переговорів
тим не менше ми всі зацікавлені в тому
щоб ці мирні переговори відбулися і
звичайно зацікавлені в кінцевому
результаті цих переговорів Але знову ж
таки територіальна цілісність є
священною складовою цих переговорів
А як щодо того що Ваша країна Литва
межує з Білорусією та російським
ексклавом калінінградської області
Наскільки Ви впевнені в тому що Росія не
вторгнеться до країн Балтії
знаєте ми маємо таких непередбачуваних
Сусідів вже досить довго і звикли
підлаштовуватися під ці геополітичні
реалії і нині Так ви маєте рацію коли
кажете що Литва відчуває себе затиснутою
між дуже мілітаризованою
калінінградською областю Та білоруссю
так у нас досить довгий кордон з
білоруссю близько 600 кілометрів тож ми
намагаємося робити усе можливе і
звичайно насамперед ми використовуємо
інструменти колективної безпеки Литва є
членом НАТО з 2004 року але Ми багато
робимо для того щоб модернізувати наші
збройні сили щоб мати в Литві елементи
передової оборони і мадридський саміт
був дуже важливим у цьому плані ми
дійсно співпрацюємо з Німеччиною наразі
ми говоримо про розширення передових
елементів оборони до рівня бригад Ми
намагаємося збільшити видатки на оборону
два з половиною відсотки ВВП цього року
і хочемо збільшити витрати до 3% ВВП
Наступного року ми дуже зацікавлені в
тому щоб ці складові були обговорені
також на саміті НАТО у вільності який
відбудеться в липні це насамперед
Передова оборона імплементація
декларації Мадридського саміту 2% ВВП як
базовий рівень а не як стеля військових
видатків і звичайно практична підтримка
України та перспективи або наближення
України до НАТО в майбутньому
розгортання бригади в Литві - це лише
одна з можливостей Ми намагаємося її
використати на 100%. для цього ми робимо
свою домашню роботу інвестуємо зараз у
створенні нових тренувальних майданчиків
у Литві Ми намагаємося інвестувати в
інфраструктуру розміщення і будемо
робити це дуже інтенсивно Протягом
наступних двох-трьох років розмістити
повноцінну бригаду ми маємо бути Готові
до 2026 року
чи вважаєте ви що ваші міжнародні
партнери достатньо поінформовані про
інші загрози які надходять з Росії
ідеться про гібридні загрози ви висунули
пропозицію внести патріарха російської
Православної Церкви до санкційного
списку ЄС як ви це обґрунтовуєте і
наскільки на вашу думку це реально
ми спостерігаємо злиття церкви з
політичними структурами в Росії і доки
Патріарх Кирило не засудить війну а я б
сказав що він навпаки підтримує війну
Росії в Україні для мене абсолютно
природно вважати що його слід включити
до санкційного списку як і інших осіб
які відіграють важливу роль у
російському суспільстві
А що про це кажуть ваші колеги в ЄС це
станеться наскільки це реалістично
Іно деякі питання потребують більше часу
для обговорення але Литва завжди
виступає за посилення санкцій тому що ми
бачили в минулому що наші санкції мають
вплив але дискусії щодо цього займають
занадто багато часу
іноді заходи виявляються слабшими ніж ми
розраховували а потім ми скаржимося що
ці санкції поки що не принесли
очікуваного результату але це тому що
санкції ймовірно були занадто слабкими
Зараз ми вже обговорюємо 11 пакет
санкцій наразі справи в російській
економіці йдуть не дуже добре але ми
хотіли би бачити ще більшого падіння
економічної активності в Росії інакше
змінити ставлення і поведінку цієї
країни буде дуже важко
На скільки ви стурбовані тим що в
країнах які підтримують Україну
спостерігається втома президент Байден
наприклад оголосив що буде знову
готуватися на посаду президента Але чи
зміниться щось якщо республіканці знову
займуть Білий дім
Наразі я не бачу жодних ознак вдома
особливо в моїй країні тому що я бачу як
практично 99% людей від щирого серця
підтримують Україну усіма засобами
гуманітарному плані ми намагаємося
підтримувати Україну військову політично
економічно і я бачу що наші партнери
інші країни роблять дуже багато для того
щоб підтримати Україну оскільки усі
розуміють що ця війна не тільки за
свободу України Ця війна за свободу усіх
нас
вони президенти Дуже дякую вам